what's up guys just got done with the gz
episode unbelievable insane are you
ready someone's getting this look at
Marty's face guys you might not
understand how legendary this item is
right here that we have go ahead and try
to find one of these you can't we got
the Smack DVD Jeezy Edition the Snowman
signed by the man himself damn that's
dope as hell guys that's one fan just
we're just getting into a fan why not
because you know what because Marty's
got this for his office boy all right
guys giving that to a fan drop your
Instagram handle it comments to be
eligible for the giveaway give this give
it to one you guys
let's go